hallo leute wir haben letzte woche eine
e-mail bekommen von harris oder harris
und er hat uns geschrieben hello kitty
please make video about the trash
depotsystem in germany my name is very
hungry sdz aus doing it or on dieses
problem haben tatsächlich viele leute in
deutschland lieber haares es gibt so
etwas wie ein mülltrennung system und
für viele ist das erstmal verwirrend es
gibt so viele tonnen was kommt wo rhein
und warum streiten deutsche nachbarn
darüber dass erzählen wir euch in diesem
video
so fangen an mit der blauen tonne die
blaue tonne ist immer für papier
zuständig und da sehen wir schon ein
fehler in der mülltrennung das hier ist
tatsächlich aus pappe gemacht aber es
ist eine kunststoffbeschichtung oder
beschichtung darauf deswegen gehört das
nicht in den papiermüll hier gehören
also rein kartons zeitungen und
ähnliches papier
das hier gehört in den verpackungsmüll
und das hier ist auch schon die
komplizierteste tonne
das ist die sogenannte wertstofftonne
oder der gelbe sack es gibt milde in
gelben säcken gesammelt wird in
deutschland und das sind eigentlich
kunststoffe und auch metalle die man
eigentlich wieder verwerten kann
das problem oder das was verwirrend ist
in deutschland ist dass das ursprünglich
dass das ein eigentlich ein anderes
system ist der gelbe sack wurde erfunden
in deutschland weil man die unternehmen
die viel verpackungsmüll produzieren
verpflichten wollte die ihre eigenen
cycling oder ihr eigene verpackungsmüll
selbst zu finanzieren und damit auch die
unternehmen in die pflicht zu nehmen
dafür zu bezahlen dass das dass der müll
ja wiederverwertet wird oder eben
entsorgt wird also dieser gelbe sack ist
im prinzip dafür da dass ihr alle
verpackungen rein tut da sind zum
beispiel drin haarshampoo verpackungen
aus dem badezimmer verpackungen von
essen plastikverpackungen jeglicher art
und auch manchmal metallverpackungen
sowas wie dosen wenn ihr zum beispiel
essen den dosen kaufen
und da sehe ich gerade so kann ich mal
hier
top aktuell habe ich hier einen skandal
aufgedeckt bei uns im haus da hat hier
jemand seine tischbeine entsorgt in
unserem gelben sack die gehören hier
natürlich nicht rein
das hier ist sperrmüll denn das ist
keine verpackung die man so wieder
verwerten kann das muss man eigentlich
in berlin mit dem auto zur müllkippe
bringen hat natürlich keiner bock drauf
deswegen tun wir das einfach hier rein
falls ihr euch fragt ob die orangen und
die gelbe tonne das gleiche sind ja die
sind das gleiche ich weiß auch nicht
warum die zwei verschiedene farben haben
wenn ihr das wissen schreibt uns einen
kommentar und es gibt übrigens auf
vielen mülltonnen auch anweisungen was
da rein gehört hier zum beispiel auf der
orangenen tonne könnt ihr sehen
es gehören dort verpackungen hinein es
können dort sachen aus der küche also
küchen müll der aus plastik und
wertstoffen besteht rein
es gehören aber nicht rein elektrogeräte
energiesparlampen batterien textilien
datenträger und holz diese dinge müssen
also außerhalb des hauses recycelt
werden und diese dinge muss man
eigentlich in deutschland auf einen
wertstoffhof oder eine müllanlage
bringen und dort extra recyceln oder zum
beispiel für batterien oder lampen die
könnt ihr meistens auch in geschäften
zurückgeben wo ihr sie kaufen könnt so
das war die gelbe tonne
jetzt haben wir hier noch glas tonnen in
einigen städten wie in berlin stehen die
glas tonnen
auch in den höfen von den häusern wie
zum beispiel gibt es grünes glas grüne
farbe
und weißes glas weiße farbe die sind bei
uns grundsätzlich immer voll denn die
leute trinken hier viel untergehen dann
die ganzen weinflaschen rhein und in
anderen städten sind diese glascontainer
jedoch irgendwo auf der straße oder in
öffentlichen plätzen das heißt ihr müsst
dann erst mal ein glas zu hause sammeln
und dann dieses glas dahin bringen wo
was ich denn da weiße flaschen im grünen
altglas da hat jemand sehr viel wein
getrunken
die gehört natürlich hier rein dann
haben wir noch die braune tonne das ist
die biotonne in die biotonne kommt
eigentlich kompostierbarer müll also
alles was von der erde aufgenommen und
verarbeitet werden kann zum beispiel
fischgräten und apfel kitchen diese
biotonne hingegen ist allerdings nicht
mit biomüll befüllt sondern
interessanterweise mit plastikmüll und
steht auch nicht dort wo die anderen
stehen
ich denke diese tonne wurde schon
rausgenommen aus investigativen gründen
denn sie wurde nicht korrekt verwendet
die letzte tonne auf unserer tour ist
die sogenannte restmülltonne und die es
in deutschland eigentlich immer schwarz
und die restmülltonne erklärt sich
eigentlich selbst alles was nicht stimmt
alles was nicht in die anderen damen
gehört also kein papier keine pappe
keine wertstoff und kein glas kommt in
die restmülltonne was noch wichtig ist
ist dass manche sachen zwar aussehen als
wären sie wertstoffe oder papier aber
sie gehören trotzdem in die
restmülltonne
zum beispiel wurde ich gerade darauf
hingewiesen dass kassenbons die man in
einem geschäft erhält die haben auch
eine chemikalie in dem in dem papier
nämlich weil sie bedruckt wurden und die
gar nicht in das papier und können nicht
wie papier wiederverwertet werden
die gern auch in den restmüll
so und zum abschluss haben wir noch mal
die top drei gründe warum sich deutsche
über die mülltrennung streiten nummer
eins ist wenn der müll falsch getrennt
ist dann wird er manchmal nicht
mitgenommen so zum beispiel unsere
biotonne die ist voll mit plastikmüll
ich kann mir vorstellen dass die nicht
mitgenommen wird und dann wird der müll
einfach nicht abgeholt und bleibt hier
stehen und stinkt und die tonnen sind
voll
darüber ärgern sich natürlich die
nachbarn punkt zwei ist dass man für
diese tonnen zahlt das heißt jede
einzelne tonne hat einen preis und all
die nachbarn hier in dem häuserblock
teilen sich diesen preis wenn eine tonne
immer voll ist weil zb keiner trend und
alle den müll in den restmüll schmeißen
dann muss man eine zweite restmülltonne
bereitstellen oder eine dritte eine
vierte das ist teuer
das ärgert auch die nachbarn und punkt 3
ist manche leute ärgert es einfach wenn
andere sich nicht an die ordnung halten
das ist in deutschland so und das ist
manchmal witzig und manchmal ärgerlich
habt ihr noch fragen zum thema
mülltrennung dann freuen wir uns über
eure kommentare
hier unten und wir werden uns bemühen
eure fragen zu beantworten
und wenn ihr lust habt noch ein paar
geschichten aus dem deutschen alltag zu
sehen und damit deutsch zu lernen
dann schaut man unsere app siedlungen
dort gibt es unter anderem eine
geschichte mit unserem freund emanuel
von your daily german dot com und der
hat auch erfahrungen mit nachbarn
gemacht die sich über die mülltrennung
aufregen
hier geht es zu unserer ettling dort
könnt ihr schritt um schritt deutsch
lernen und hier freuen wir uns auf eure
kommentare
tschüss und bis nächste woche
[Musik]